I think I just figured out why Disney movies kill off the parents.
I'm a huge Disney adult,
and other than knowing that Walt probably had some, like,
very complex dramatic issues with his own parents,
I think it's also because all of these adventures and all of these
like, dangerous situations that these main characters
who are children get themselves into
or adolescents get themselves into
would never happen if they had their mom or dad around.
Like Elsa not being able to negotiate her powers.
Her parents would have helped her emotional regulate.
Cinderella being abused by her stepmother
never would have happened if her dad was around.
Belle basically having to be a caretaker for her father
and take places with her dad
who found himself in like
Beast jail never would have happened.
The mom would never let that happen.
Who else would be able to counsel Ariel through her like,
cross species crush? Better than a mom
who's probably already crushed on a couple humans in her day?
They have to not have parents,
because if they had good parents or a present parent,
none of these adventures would happen.
They're too dangerous or are a result of terrible advice.
Having a solid nuclear family would almost like ruin the whole thing.
Tarzan wouldn't be raised by gorillas.
He probably would have found his way back to England
cause his parents would have gotten them rescued.
I think Mulan is the only one who has A solid mom and dad.
And honestly, she was sacrificing herself for her father,
which she had to do in the middle of the night
because her parents would never.
Her parents would never be okay with that.
So maybe in some sort of way,
it's kind of sweet that they're all orphans.
Or at least that's how I'm gonna look at it from now on.